[Música]
empreender é político vocês devem estar
achando um pouco estranha essa minha
afirmação
mas pensem comigo se você empreende você
pode certa forma resolver um problema
social pela via do mercado
algum tempo atrás eu conheci uma
empreendedora e o produto específico que
ela desenvolvia e vendia eram rosquinhas
de amamentação
essas outras 500 absorventes e laváveis
elas ajudavam na sensibilidade dos seios
durante o período lactante não aliviavam
muito essa dor
essas rosquinhas elas estão sobre
registro de patente mas quantas mulheres
amamentam
como assim leite faça como assim
incomoda e fica aparente na verdade é
durante o período de lactação esse leite
ele pode sim vai saber seios e muitas
mulheres elas retornam ao mercado de
trabalho e o tempo que elas têm entre
amada ea necessidade de amamentação do
bebê ela não consegue casar então
excelente e vai vazar e ele vai aparecer
então na verdade essa ideia é genial
acontece que muitas vezes quando essas
mulheres se submetem suas idéias
alguns investidores elas são
desacreditados pelo mercado
elas são desacreditados quanto às
chances de venda e aderência dos seus
produtos e alcance
quando essas mulheres criam produtos
exclusivamente para outras mulheres elas
podem serem compreendidas as bancas de
investimento
elas são formadas majoritariamente por
homens que muitas vezes
não compreendem as necessidades
específicas das mulheres
o viés das bancas é o masculino e muitas
vezes é só com essa lente que ele
enxerga o mundo em meados de julho e
agosto deste ano 1 saiu uma pesquisa do
bcg banking consulting grupo que dizia o
seguinte quando mulheres empresárias
buscavam as bancas de investimento para
apresentar os seus produtos e serviços e
receber algum investimento por parte
deles
elas recebiam em média 1 1 bilhão de
dólares a menos do que os homens
muitas vezes porque simplesmente esses
investidores não conseguiam entender o
produto ou serviço que elas estavam
propondo como inovador no mercado
nessa mesma pesquisa foi constatado que
os homens ao apresentarem as suas
propostas por conta do seu discurso e
diretamente ao encontro da expectativa
do investidor
eles recebiam investimentos ainda que
seus produtos não fossem tão inovadores
a despeito t nessa mesma pesquisa foi
constatado que para cada 1 dólar
investido no negócio feminino retorno
ele era de 71 centavos enquanto que para
os homens esse mesmo dólar investido
retornava em 31 centavos não lhes parece
pouco coerente não lhes parece um pouco
estranho o fato de que mesmo com maior
retorno e melhores resultados
os negócios femininos recebam menos
investimento
de que forma a gente pode compreender
dentro desse universo do ecossistema de
empreendedorismo ou de startup na vida
nós tendemos a nos associarmos a paris
nós buscamos semelhantes para que a
gente possa interagir
então a gente pode compreender que
homens investidores investem seu
dinheiro em outros homens empreendedores
por semelhança por se identificarem
mas aí eu pergunto será que essa
homogeneidade
ela é boa para a inovação será que essa
homogeneidade é boa para que nós
possamos avançar como sociedade
dentro desse mesmo universo analisando
tudo isso que acontece com relação às
mulheres empreendedoras ea maneira como
a sociedade ela é construída
eu percebi e mais algumas outras
pesquisas que nós mulheres sempre temos
pesquisas pra provar alguns dos pontos
que a gente trabalho que dentro de si
dessa realidade até mesmo a aparência
feminina ela conta
dentro dessa realidade a maneira como a
gente se veste hoje se comporta também
conta
então vou pedir que vocês olhem para a
realidade de vocês agora e ajudem a
montar um cenário sem imaginem que as
nove horas da noite dentro de uma
reunião de negócios tem lá uma pessoa
com o cabelo completamente desgrenhado a
roupa amassada suando cansado e essa
pessoa está diante de outros
investidores de estoril está falando de
negócios nove da noite conseguiria
imaginar a cena
isso é pra vocês que é uma mulher nessa
situação eu descreva cena e conto pra
vocês no final que é um homem
automaticamente essa imagem vai estar
associado ao nosso e é um workaholic
ele é um criativo que está exausto não
tem tempo pra pensar em ter o cabelo e
também passar essa camisa
se a gente começa a imaginar que uma
mulher
a gente já pensa que desleixo porque ela
não perde o cabelo que roupa amassada
que ouro
eu não vou botar um real nesse negócio
incrível mas verdadeiro
quando acontece uma coisa dessas dentro
do universo de uma mulher quando ela vai
buscar investimento e o produto dela não
consegue aderência quando ela vai para
uma reunião de negócios e era julgada
pela aparência dela ela não desiste
ela vai buscar alternativas e aí você
pode dizer pra mim mais ana
isso é uma característica de todo
empreendedor
todos são resilientes e perseverantes
vão buscar alternativas e eu concordo
plenamente com vocês e é por isso que eu
vou trazer vocês pra cá essa mulher que
não conseguiu investimento que não
conseguiu nada naquela reunião que ela
vai pensar
ela vai falar poxa eu vou buscar
alternativas têm uma feira de
empreendedorismo gigantesca acontecendo
agora vou pegar meus filhos pelas mãos e
vou lá participar de palestras vou fazer
networking ou compreender como esse
ecossistema funciona
ela enche o peito de otimismo e vai mas
o papel aí a feira não permite a entrada
de crianças com ou sem paz como
acompanhantes e agora ela poderia pagar
uma cuidadora para ficar com essas
crianças mas não tem dinheiro
essa criança as crianças poderiam ficar
com o pai mas a feira acontece a final
de semana o pai tem compromisso com os
amigos trabalhou a semana toda é o único
momento de lazer que ele tem e os avós e
os parentes estão em outro estado se ele
estivesse aqui eles ajudavam
definitivamente uma feira de negócios
não é lugar para crianças e ela pudesse
ela levaria essas crianças ao parque ao
cinema é um bom médico e é pra isso que
ela precisa na feira que ela tenha
recursos suficientes para poder dar as
oportunidades que ela gostaria de dar
esses vacilos e não levará à feira
mas ana
o que muda quando uma mulher lidera
o que muda quando uma mulher empreende
por que você insiste tanto nisso há
algum tempo atrás eu estava passeando no
instagram
e eu me deparei com uma imagem que eu
considerei extremamente forte
era uma mulher negra vestida de maneira
impecável em frente a uma mesa com dez
homens brancos
eles perguntavam assim pra ela
como você pretende inovar na nossa
organização não tinha resposta a imagem
na minha cabeça ela respondia eu eu eu
ea minha perspectiva de vida eu ea minha
história
simples né não
não é tão simples assim não seria
simples se a gente desconsiderasse tudo
o que vem junto de uma mulher negra
dentro de um ambiente de negócios ea
gente desconsiderasse tudo que vem junto
de uma mulher no ambiente de negócios
quando uma mulher negra ou quando uma
outra mulher ela enquanto sua existência
dentro de um ambiente majoritariamente
masculino e branco
ela mexe com as estruturas postas
ela desafia normas de conduta que foram
desenhadas a partir do paradigma que nos
formou a todos em que hierarquia
autoridade e força estão diretamente
ligados à competência sucesso e êxito e
o que eu quero que vocês percebam agora
é que até mesmo os homens que não têm
essas características
eles ficam à margem do conceito de
sucesso quando uma mulher empreende e se
lançar dentro desse ambiente
ela desafia a essas estruturas e ela
traz características architect camente
ligadas ao feminino
tais como empatia
a intuição horizontalidade nesse momento
em que ela transforma essas relações e
mostra que é possível uma realidade em
que o êxito não esteja necessariamente
ligado à força
ela rompe com esse paradigma e todos nós
ganhamos
durante cerca de 16 ou 17 anos
eu atuei no mercado corporativo como
advogados estrategista e o meu trabalho
era garantir que todos aqueles
detentores do 1% das riquezas
continuassem detendo 1% das riquezas
problema nenhum nisso até que nessa
realidade as minhas ideias inovadoras e
criativas encontraram resistência
foi então que eu me dei conta da
complexidade da estrutura dominante e
como ela nos atinge a todos
se eu sou uma mulher que até então se
considerava emancipada e que não via
qualquer possibilidade de alguma coisa
para a minha ascensão profissional
eu percebi que o problema não era só meu
era nós ea partir do momento que esse
problema se tornou nós
eu precisava fazer alguma coisa a luz
que me fez enxergar a estrutura da qual
fazia parte o iluminou também o meu
propósito a minha energia e o meu
esforço finalmente encontrava a
necessidade de alguém de todas as
mulheres incluindo as que eu não
conhecia as que eu não conheço e
provavelmente não conhecer e as palavras
de ordem hoje no ambiente de negócios é
uma inovação
a humanidade foi nesse momento que
começou a minha jornada empreendedora e
o que eu vi foi o meu relato até aqui e
o que eu descobri é que quando uma
mulher compreende élin cabeça a
transformação social porque existirem
sendo mulher é um ato político em
empreender em sendo mulher é revolução
quando nós lançamos nossos corpos em
ambientes de negócio que não estão
preparados para a nossa forma de gestão
a gente acende a luz de uma sociedade
inteira para problemas que nunca antes
foram vistos a gente dá oportunidade que
a sociedade resolva problemas que ela
jamais conseguiu identificar como a
gente pode falar em inovação e
humanização se os mesmos agentes de
sempre é quem toma as decisões sobre o
que é ou não é inovação
quando a diversidade ela entra dentro do
universo dos negócios ela mostra que
existem realidades diferentes com
necessidades diversas e as chances de
você conseguir uma disrupção de fato
inovadora é infinitamente maior
a sociedade como nós conhecemos hoje
os produtos e serviços que estão nos
mesmos no mercado da maneira como estão
sendo postos hoje eles não nos atendem a
todos vocês conseguem compreender vocês
conseguem pensar de maneira melhor de
inovado que a diversidade de idéias ea
pluralidade de opiniões e de
experiências
vocês conseguem imaginar alguma maneira
melhor de você alcançar a inovação se
não for por meio da contrariedades de
idéias
eu não para avançarmos como sociedade
precisamos identificar que existe uma
realidade que nós não conhecemos que
somos todos diversos
independente de a gente saber o impacto
da nossa singularidade conhecemos
experiências diferentes e têm
as necessidades específicas e é com isso
que nós transformamos a sociedade a
partir do momento que eu consigo
compreender que somos completamente
diferentes e portanto complementares
eu aceito que somos co dependentes e que
precisamos uns dos outros para que
dentro de cada um de nós dentro da nossa
diversidade possamos avançar como
sociedade
é impossível pensar no modelo de
sociedade mais justa e equânime que não
deu oportunidade para novos agentes de
transformação fazerem parte dos
processos decisórios inovadores
executivos é contraditório imaginar que
nós vamos conseguir avançar como
sociedades em que nós possamos nos
apropriar dos problemas que me cercam
entender a responsabilidade que temos em
cada um deles e agir
o que eu quero convidar vocês aqui hoje
é para que compreendam cada um de vocês
a singularidade a potência da
adversidade que carregam quiserem pela
liberdade de uns dos outros porque
liberdade mútua é desenvolvimento social
e lembrarmos que nunca nenhum de nós é
tão bom quanto todos nós juntos e quando
você é uma mulher existir é político e
empreender é um ato político
muito obrigada
[Música]
[Aplausos]